[Music]
the legend of zelda is now
35 years old a little over one year
older than i am
look at that wasn't i cute no look at
that mullet
anyway to celebrate the anniversary i
want to do a quick video about the game
that started it all the legend of zelda
on nes from 1986.
now this isn't going to be like a
history video about the development of
the game there are plenty of videos out
there who've done an excellent job of
telling that story this is more like a
little personal tribute
despite almost sharing a birthday with
the nes classic
i actually didn't play this game until
many many years later
my first experience with the series was
ocarina of time and before that time
i was more of a mario kid my mom used to
work at a local video store and for
those who were born
after netflix was the place to be if you
wanted to get your hands on a good movie
or some other types of entertainment if
you know what i mean
this included video games as well you
could even rent the console itself to go
with it
and since i was still very young around
4 years if i recall correctly my mom
sometimes had to take me to work with
her whenever there was no one around to
babysit me
naturally this was very boring for a 4
year old since i wasn't allowed to just
roam around the store and potentially
break stuff or
walk into the wrong section of the store
alright enough of that so they had this
little back room behind the counter
where the
employees would go on their coffee break
and such which is where i had to stay
while my mom was on her shift
lucky for me the back room had an nes
setup and this little room is literally
where my love for video games started i
would play the original super mario
brothers for
hours upon end and it wasn't long until
i got my own system at home then the
super nintendo
n64 and with the exception of the
virtual boy every other nintendo console
since then
after finishing ocarina of time and
majora's mask we had to wait a while
before the wind waker would finally show
up so in the meantime i decided to pick
up some of the older games which
included the original and one of the
first things i noticed was
this game is hard as balls now don't get
me wrong the first mario wasn't the
easiest to complete
either especially for a 4 year old but
at least it was easy to comprehend
move to the right don't touch enemies
don't fall to your death there are some
secrets and occasional riddles here and
there but almost none of it is mandatory
it just makes the game easier you also
didn't have to worry about grinding
finding better gear or anything like
that zelda on the other hand was all
about secrets
some of them are optional but most of
them are crucial to reach the end and
unless you're some crazy speedrunner
even the optional stuff is almost
required to do
if you want to stand a chance and this
has everything to do with the way the
game scaled its difficulty
nowadays most games give you a chance to
ease into the experience first and then
gradually increase the challenge as you
become better at the game
zelda on the nes didn't do that in fact
it kinda did the opposite
it starts out really hard and then
slowly becomes more doable as you press
on
you get dropped in this huge map for the
time and you're completely left to your
own devices
you have no idea where to go enemies
drain your hp quicker than you can say
and there are no tutorials or practice
stages obviously this kind of game
design wouldn't fly nowadays
since games are now in the mainstream
people like to know what the goal is and
not immediately get their ass handed to
them as soon as they boot up the game
even dark souls which is notorious for
its difficulty in the modern era
still gives you a break in the first
section of the game with enemies that
don't even fight back
giving you a chance to get accustomed to
the controls in the combat it isn't
until about the 20-minute mark that you
encounter your first enemy who doesn't
mess around
the original zelda gives you one screen
one screen of safety not infested by
enemies
from here no matter what direction you
take off in you will immediately run
into your first batch of baddies
and because you only have 3 hearts to
start with 6 hits means
death and even less when being hit by
blue enemies your shield does block
projectiles but not direct hits from the
enemy itself
and some projectiles you can't block
until you buy the magic shield
from the starting point it takes a
minimum of 6 screens to get to the first
level or dungeon and that's if you know
where you're going
6 screens which all include various
types of enemies and like i said most
people on their first playthrough would
have had no idea where they were going
and probably wandered around far
outside those six screens it's no
surprise then that many people died in
just the first few minutes of playing to
make things
a bit more manageable the game's manual
came with a map of the overworld which
was gracious enough to point out the
first four dungeons though it did
obscure some parts of the world to leave
some room for surprises
it also gave tips on how to beat certain
enemies how to find secrets finding
merchants and gathering up your strength
it even spoils all the items you'll be
able to find in the game which
is very unconventional for a zelda game
nowadays can you imagine if twilight
princess straight up told you beforehand
about the spinner or the ball and chain
anyway even with all this information
you are mostly still left in the dark as
secrets aren't exactly straightforward
in this game there is very little that
indicates that a secret is there
no cracks embalmable walls no clear
indication which bush can be burned or
not
not to mention it will take a while
before you even get the tools you need
to find them
once you find your first shop and
realize you can buy say the candle you
first need to roam around and collect
rupees which means dealing with lots of
enemies in your fragile state
the same thing goes for collecting bombs
which you also get from enemies
the overworld starts out insanely hard
and then gets easier
once you start finding and buying more
stuff like the blue ring which decreases
damage taken by half
the magic shield which allows you to
block every type of projectile and more
quality of life improvements like heart
containers and better swords i totally
get why this game scares away players
nowadays
it's such an unconventional approach to
difficulty by modern standards
i myself put this game on the back
burner at least three or four times over
the years
every time i started a new game trying
to get as far as possible and then
getting stumped because i just
couldn't do it once you're outfitted
with better equipment and increase your
hp a couple of times
the overworld becomes manageable for the
most part you get more and more
comfortable just roaming around beating
enemies finding caves and collecting
resources
and the more you do this the easier it
gets to explore and find more so the
difficulty ramp for the overworld itself
looks like this
but if you thought you were in the clear
you are mistaken because the same thing
cannot be said for the game's dungeons
this graph looks more like this the
first 5 dungeons ramp up mildly but then
it hits you with
level 6 which is an absolute nightmare
on your first playthrough and even now
after having beaten the game multiple
times with randomizers included this is
still a part of the game i
always dread and this is mostly due to
these bastards
right here the blue wiz robes if there's
a place in hell for video game enemies
these guys are one of my prime
candidates for banishment to the fiery
pits
these guys are insane they don't take
any back or hits done
are always on the move and they can face
through walls and blocks
and once they have you in your sights
they don't just shoot one projectile
like their orange counterparts
instead they bombard you with no break
in between to get a hit in all the while
they constantly move towards you so even
if you block
every beam you will still get hit by
them if you just stand there
they also have no notable weakness aside
from the sword and can take
quite some abuse and do a lot of damage
themselves what's also funny is that in
this dungeon you find the magic rod
which you would think will make dealing
with them a lot easier
you know like in other zelda games where
the main item is often the key to
beating enemies which were previously a
pain to defeat
but nope the one does absolutely nothing
against them
just great times all around level 7 is
actually a lot easier than 6
and 8 falls slightly below 6 but still
pretty damn hard
but the torture doesn't end there oh no
level 9 takes everything that made 6 and
8 difficult
and puts it on steroids it's the biggest
dungeon of them all
has many and i mean many optional rooms
and secret doorways
making the dungeon one giant maze filled
with monsters
a monster maze if you will to anyone
who's beaten this dungeon without safe
states
i salute you one thing i really
appreciate about this game though is how
finding a dungeon is a really big deal
as mentioned before the locations of the
first four dungeons are hinted at on the
map inside the manual but after that
it's up to you to find the remaining
five and some of these
are hidden very well zelda 2 continued
this trend but starting with a link to
the past
dungeons were no longer a big mystery i
mean they are literally spelled out on
the map and even have a set order
later 3d games while not showing them on
the map do point you in their general
direction
either through your companion or the
story or simply by barring off
everything else in the overworld so by
process of elimination you will get
there no problem which is why for breath
of the wild
i think it's a shame that they didn't go
for more traditional dungeons
if anything this would have been a great
game to hide complex dungeons in the
overworld without anyone telling you
where they are but hey
maybe the sequel will of all classic
zelda games the original two probably
hold up the least
many can still boot up a link to the
past or link's awakening and still enjoy
it a great deal since by that time the
games got more streamlined and easy to
understand
the grandfather of zelda games
definitely isn't the most accessible
game out there
yet the series still owes so much to
this one game it introduced many zelda
staples which we still see today
in some shape or form the tradition of
getting a heart container after a boss
fight the aspect of bombing walls
finding dungeons and getting the items
inside even the classic lore of the hero
princess and ganon all find their origin
here and although
an outdated concept now i think there's
a charm to reading a book that teaches
you things about the world
while you play the game it's almost like
having a survival book with you while
you venture out into the wild
the game was born from miyamoto's
imagination and childhood memories of
exploring a vast world
zelda started out as an open world game
then slowly dipped more and more into
linear territory only to revive the opel
world concept
30 years later in 2017 and look at where
we are now
still looking forward to that new game
in the franchise zelda is one of the
longest running series in gaming history
soon to be 21 games strong not counting
spin-offs and i hope that another 35
years from now
70 year old me will still be celebrating
this franchise and playing or
anticipating the next game
thank you for watching
you